Hi zusammen, heute gibt's ein falsches Börek!
Jetzt denkt ihr euch: "Was, falsches Börek? Wie kannst du das tun?"
Aber manchmal muss es einfach schnell gehen und einfach und vor allem jetzt!
Hamza und ich haben eine richtig leckere Torte in der Kühlung
und warten eigentlich nur darauf, die verspeisen zu können
und jetzt brauchen wir so'n Schmankerl für zwischendurch, ne?
[Hamza] Ja!
Genau!
[Hamza] Für den kleinen Hunger!
[Kiki] Für den kleinen Hunger! Ich wollt grad sagen: Du bist irgendwie kein Mann der großen Worte heute!
[Hamza] Nein, nein, nein!
[Kiki] Aber ich übernehme das schon! Also!
Heute machen wir wirklich so eine Art Börek aus der Pfanne mit Käse
Und das ist so easy: Ihr müsst nur Zutaten zusammenrühren und ausbacken.
Und dafür habe ich jetzt hier die folgenden Zutaten:
Milch, da gebe ich direkt Mehl mit rein.
Und ich schreibe euch natürlich die ganz genauen Mengenangaben in die..?
[Hamza] Infobox!
[Kiki] Warum gähnst du?!
[Hamza] Genau da habe ich gegähnt!
[Kiki] *lacht*
Okay. Die ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen wie immer in der Infobox!
So, jetzt erstmal Mehl mit Milch verrühren.
Jetzt das Ei dazugeben.
So, Käse..
Mit drin sind jetzt Käse, Oregano, Petersilie schön fein gehackt, Salz und Pfeffer.
Und die wichtigste Zutat ist jetzt noch Backpulver, das gebe ich jetzt auch noch mit dazu.
Und jetzt alles gut verrühren
und dann erhitze ich auch schon auf mittlerer Stufe etwas Öl in meiner beschichteten Pfanne.
Ich hab jetzt Olivenöl genommen, ich finde das gibt einfach nochmal einen richtig leckeren Geschmack.
Ihr dürft es nicht zu sehr erhitzen, das ist ganz wichtig.
Ich hab's jetzt hier bei mittlerer Stufe erwärmt und jetzt gebe ich die gesamte Masse dazu.
Ich nehme jetzt meine 20cm Pfanne.
Ihr könntet auch eine größere Pfanne nehmen, dann wird es allerdings dünner
und dann braucht es nicht so lange um durchzugaren.
Und ganz, ganz wichtig: Gebt dann direkt danach auch den Deckel drauf
und bratet das so von beiden Seiten ca. 8min an.
Es kann sein, dass die zweite Seite nicht ganz so lange braucht.
Habt auf jeden Fall immer ein Auge drauf.
[Hamza] Ich bin mal richtig gespannt auf's Rezept! Ich kann mir grad gar nichts drunter vorstellen.
Das wird richtig lecker. Ich glaube ich muss direkt noch 'nen zweiten machen!
Mein Pfannenbörek ist jetzt fertig.
Es hat von der zweiten Seite auch ca. 8min gedauert
aber ich bin mit der Hitze so ein bisschen runtergegangen.
Weil es soll wirklich nur so vor sich hin...dämpfen? Sagt man das so?
Also es soll nicht braten oder sowas.
Und jetzt müsste es auch von innen gar sein und von unten hab ich mir das auch mal angeschaut.
Sieht richtig, richtig gut aus!
Und ja, jetzt lassen wir uns das Ganze schmecken!
Ihr könnt das natürlich auch zum Frühstück machen
und noch nebenbei vielleicht noch ein paar Tomaten, Gurken etc. servieren.
Oder halt als Abendessen auch sehr, sehr lecker!
[Kiki] So! Wir sind jetzt angelangt beim Tasty Table!
[Hamza] Tasty Table!
[Hamza] Also mit der Hand essen wir das jetzt, ne?
[Kiki] Ich würd sagen ja! Wofür Messer und Gabel?
[Hamza] Das erinnert mich irgendwie an so eine Fusion aus Omelett und Brot!
[Kiki] Mmmh!
[Kiki] Innere zeigen, schön in die Kamera!
[Hamza] So?
[Kiki] Näher ran! Jaja, jetzt ist es scharf!
[Hamza] Scharf?
[Hamza] Du hast echt Probleme - du kannst auch auf den Bildschirm einfach drücken, dann wird das scharf Kiki!
[Kiki] Okay!
[Hamza] Cool?
[Kiki] M-hm!
[Hamza] Okay! Darf ich jetzt probieren?
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] So, probieren wir's mal! Isst man das auch mit Soße oder so Dips?
[Kiki] Also ich hab hier einen Joghurt mit Knoblauch hingelegt aber du kannst es auch einfach so essen.
[Kiki] Oh du hast schon abgebissen! *lacht*
[Kiki] Und, wie ist der erste Eindruck?
[Hamza] Also ich muss sagen durch die Petersilie schmeckt das extremst türkisch.
[Hamza] Ich hab mir eh schon gedacht: "Was macht die da? Wat rührt die da zusammen?"
[Hamza] Aber jetzt verstehe ich das, das schmeckt wie so eine Art Pfannenbrot.
[Hamza] Ich hab ehrlich gesagt gedacht das wird ein Omelett aber das schmeckt eher nach Brot.
[Kiki] Es ist ja nur ein einziges Ei drin!
[Hamza] Ja, ja.
[Kiki] Das ist mehr Brot als Omelett.
[Hamza] Also zum Frühstück - mega!
[Hamza] Also muss man echt sagen, das wird bestimmt -
[Hamza] Wenn du hier so den ganzen Tisch Frühstück hast und dann sowas dazwischen bekommst - richtig geil!
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] Gefällt mir gut, schmeckt gut!
[Kiki] Danke!
[Hamza] Hat was!
[Hamza] Weißt du was cool ist auch daran?
[Hamza] Du hast da hammer viel Käse reingehauen aber den schmeckst du nicht so krass raus, ne?
[Hamza] Man fühlt sich gar nicht schlecht dabei! *lacht*
[Kiki] Nein aber weißt du, was auch gut passen würde? Schafskäse!
[Hamza] Schafskäse? Boah ja, Schafskäse!
[Kiki] Kann man auch reinmachen! Oder einfach Suçuk mit reintun!
[Hamza] Vielleicht auch so klein geschnittene Zwiebeln!
[Kiki] Das geht auch!
[Hamza] Ja?
[Kiki] Man könnte Zwiebeln automatisch direkt schon mit reintun.
[Kiki] Ich würd vorschlagen: Macht das unbedingt mal nach..
[Kiki] ..wenn ihr einfach mal so'n Highlight am Frühstückstisch haben möchtet.
[Kiki] Oder genau, abends!
[Kiki] Manchmal wissen wir auch abends gar nicht, was wir essen sollen!
[Hamza] Stimmt, das kann man auch gut abends essen.
[Kiki] So "Wat mach ich jetzt?" und dann ist das hier finde ich perfekt geeignet.
[Kiki] Du hast es auch echt toll beschrieben muss ich sagen!
[Kiki] Da muss ich dir einen Klatscher geben!
[Kiki] Okay! Also ich lass mir das jetzt noch schmecken.
[Kiki] Und ich wünsche euch ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
[Kiki] Tschüss!
[Hamza] Eure Kiki!
[Kiki] Und der Hamza!
[Kiki] Ich bin glücklich!
[Kiki] Was soll ich sagen? Ich bin glücklich!
[Kiki] *lacht*